thomas jefferson may have written the
words all men are created equal
but he really didn't do very much in his
life to make that happen
you're saying to tear down jefferson and
replace it with harriet tubman
i didn't say that don't put words in my
mouth who would you say the best
president we've had in the last hundred
years
are you serious i love this country and
it changed my life and i'm asking you
these are ridiculous questions this is
man sitting here
you have to be the greatest what is mine
you can't answer that can you yeah i did
say it what is it ask the guy you're in
the studio with ask
whatever i'm interviewing you not them i
didn't ask you
why you think anything i know who wrote
the declaration of independence
i don't disagree with you on a lot of
things i'm an immigrant so am i
were you born here no i wasn't i don't
answer
questions like this questions
asking me who's my favorite because your
favorite president said thomas jefferson
represents what's best in america that's
why what a [ __ ] [ __ ]
[Music]
so with all the debates taking place
about statues coming on we decided to
reach out to lucian truscott which is a
very interesting story he is
thomas jefferson's sixth great grandson
now he has a
resume that must be talked about he has
been writing
uh for over uh 50 years as a journalist
novelist and screenwriter
uh he has cover stories such as
watergate the stonewall riots
wars in lebanon iraq afghanistan he's
written
five best selling novels done a lot of
work
and recently he suggested that the
jefferson memorial must be taken down
and replaced by harriet tubman's
memorial
so we decided to reach out lucian truska
thank you so much for being a guest on
valuetainment
thanks for having me so opening question
very simple that paper that article you
wrote on new york times
you you explained your position you
explain where you're at you explain
where
uh uh uh you know why you think this
ought to be taking place but maybe for
the audience that hasn't written the
article
why do you think jefferson's memorial
must be taken down taken down and
replaced by harriet tubman
well i didn't say it must be taken down
um i i made a suggestion that
that that sort of that it might be time
that we considered
taking down jefferson's memorial because
because of everything that's going on in
the country today
i think a lot of things are are being
re-examined right now
um you know the the pentagon just
recently
uh banned the use of the confederate
flag
uh states around the country including
in the south are taking down
uh monuments to confederate generals and
that sort of thing and i think it's i
think it's time that we had a look at
some of the worship that's been given to
some of our founding fathers one of whom
is thomas jefferson
in in my article what i said was i think
that jefferson's
home at monticello is a much
better memorial to him than the statue
that
that that stands in washington d.c
because the the his home at monticello
nowadays anyway tells the whole story of
jefferson
jefferson the whole man including um uh
his flaws and some of the and some of
the aspects of him that
were just straight ahead immoral
including the fact that he owned over
600 slaves during his lifetime
but if you if you visit monticello today
you'll learn about that history of
slavery you'll learn about slave life at
monticello
you'll learn that jefferson fathered six
children with
his slave sally hemmings and
and you'll learn that that slaves built
monticello they built the house they
built the outbuildings
they worked the land they made
monticello possible
when you go to the jefferson memorial
martian at gc on the other hand
what you see is this grand 19 foot
tall statue to to jeff of jefferson
and inscriptions on the walls that
that um celebrate that some of his great
writings and
and great sayings but the problem with
that is
jefferson may have written the words um
all men are created equal
but he really didn't do very much in his
life to
to make that happen and um
and so i suggested that that it might be
time to take down the
the monument to jefferson and and
replace it then i thought
well who can you replace thomas
jefferson with
and then i thought well maybe we ought
to instead of worshiping these so-called
founding fathers that
i've been hearing about for 50 years of
my life
maybe it's time to honor some of
america's founding mothers and one of
them is harriet tubman harriet tubman
was a slave
who escaped slavery um set helped to set
up the underground railroad to help
escape slaves get out of slavery
and then during the civil war fought on
the side of the union
as an as an armed scout against the
confederate
army and then after the civil war she
worked
for the rights of of freed slaves
um you know in this way i think that
harriet tubman
really contributed to the founding of
the country
after slavery after 1865.
you know the united states wasn't just
founded
when jefferson wrote the declaration of
independence
in the 18th century it's been going
through a founding
over 200 years and i think it's time
that we started
celebrating some of the the people that
have helped
found and helped form a more perfect
union
like harriet tubman has this week we
just
had the death of another founder
uh john lewis who worked so hard for
uh civil rights in the 1960s and
then of course marched across the edmond
paris bridge with
all the people that marched that day and
uh
and and spent his entire life
working for civil rights uh in the south
and these are these harriet tubman and
john lewis are great great
people great americans and i think it's
time to honor people like them
so it's a tragedy what happened with
john lewis obviously he's
i think i can say admired adored
respected by many
uh uh he's got a lot of love going on
and with harriet tubman i don't think
uh anybody would dispute the fact that
to put up a statue but
to read what you said in the article you
said that's why we don't need the
jefferson memorial to celebrate him you
should not be honored with a bronze
statue 19 feet tall surrounded by
colonia of white marble the time to
honor the slave owning founders of our
imperfect union has passed the ground
which should have moved long past
has at last shifted beneath us and it's
time to honor one of our founding
mothers a woman who fought as an escaped
slave to free
those still enslaved who fought as an
armed
scout of the union army against the
confederacy a woman who helped to bring
into being a more perfect union after a
slavery process that continues to this
day in jefferson's place there should be
another statue it should be harriet
tubman okay so that's in the article
fine that makes sense
well my question for you would be why
replace it
why not just put it in a different place
and leave jefferson memorial where it's
at
well i think that i said in the article
i mean if you've got the article there
in front of you then you've read it
the written and i just gave you a reason
assuming that we should do that viewers
haven't seen it assume the viewers
haven't seen it
so your your your suggestion
isn't that you know you're saying the
jefferson statute
you know at his 5 000 acres of
plantation is plenty if you really want
to find out his history go there
there's no need to have a 19 for statue
let's tear that one down and replace
what harry tubman
what i'm asking is why don't we keep
that one since it's part of history and
let's just put another statue of harry
tubman
well you could do that but i think it's
time to honor
other people in the same way that we
honored
uh thomas jefferson and the way to honor
someone in the same way you honored
thomas jefferson is
put a statue where his statue was also
tear him down and put him put her up
well you keep using the words tear them
down
uh i never use those words in my article
look down at my article
you've got it in front you've got it in
front of you there look down at my
article and see if you see the words
tear them down
what what what way would you bring it
down so what's the proper word to use
you can you can move jefferson's statue
move jefferson statue to monticello
i don't care what that is i got it okay
that makes sense as a matter of fact
so what you're saying don't put words in
my mouth don't say
don't tell these listeners that i said
tear down thomas
thomas jefferson i never said you said
tear down i just said why would we want
to tear it down why not
keep it where it's at and let's put
harriet tubman somewhere else
you know you're saying it again aren't
you
you're saying why why wouldn't you want
to tear it down
i didn't say that don't put words in my
mouth
let me give the most technically
accurate statement here
why physically move it from the place
the current statue is at to another
place
and put harriet tubman in the same exact
real estate that thomas jefferson is
currently in
because i said that it's time that we
honored some some people other than
these so-called founding fathers of ours
and i think it's time that we honored a
founding mother
lucian let me ask you what what is what
what country would you say is the
greatest country in the world
are you serious are you going to sit
here and ask me
i am questions like this i am
what do you think is the greatest
country in the world
i i mean i'm i lived in iran 10 years i
lived there when uh
romania was there and couldn't wait to
leave iran and went to germany lived at
a refugee camp
and after living at germany in a refugee
camp for two years came to the states it
was a dream to come to america
i came here and served at the 101st
airborne division aerosol proudly
because i love this country and it
changed my life and i'm asking you
what do you think is the greatest
country oh i think that i think the
united states of america is the greatest
country in the world
why do you think it is
why do i think it is why do you i
explain mine why do you think it is
why do i think the united states is the
greatest country in the world
yes what kind of questions are these
you're asking
me
lucien you asked me why i think i didn't
ask
i didn't ask you why you think anything
i asked you
what you thought the greatest country
and in the world what do you use
i didn't ask you why what do you think i
i don't care
why you think the united states is the
greatest country i do i'm asking you why
because i say it is that's why based on
what premise
based on the premise that i say it's the
greatest country in the world
do you think declaration of independence
has something to do with it
what do you think the declaration of
independence has something to do with it
yeah i think the declaration of
who wrote it huh who wrote it
hey you know what i'm not going to sit
here and go through this
pity pat nitpicky little
pity pat little nitpicky line of
questioning you're giving me
i know who wrote the declaration of
independence my sixth great-grandfather
wrote why undermine them
i'm not undermining thomas jefferson
removing his statutes do you think it
undermined do you
you know i got criticized a lot when i
took my sally hemmings cousins to
monticello
because people said that i was
undermining thomas jefferson
by by showing that thomas jefferson
fathered children with a slave
i don't think it undermines thomas
jefferson i don't think it is
i don't know what to do then i don't
think what i'm suggesting
undermines thomas jefferson either
there's a big difference between
bringing people together which i think
you did in 1999 or 1998
which was the first family reunion from
both sides which was a beautiful thing
you did
that's a form of a union that's bringing
people together but why
decide to remove his statue well because
i think maybe we're bringing people to
get different people together now by
removing a statue
you know how do you think black people
think
about uh especially the ones who are
descended from slaves
how do you think that they think when
they go to see
thomas jefferson 19 feet tall in this
big monument in washington d.c
i have one of my hemming's cousins
shannon lanier
that wrote an article for cnn and he he
suggested taking down
thomas jefferson's statute in fact i
don't really understand why you're so
offended by this
why i'm offended by this
you and i are living in a country where
we're free to say whatever we can you
can totally disagree with me and i can
disagree with you because we live in
america
yeah and this happened because a lot of
people sacrificed for us to get here
don't you think
sure there's value in that isn't there
sure okay so i mean what you're saying
right now it's like same thing as me
saying
should jews call for the pyramids to be
torn down since they were most likely
built by israelites
what should should prophet mohammed who
was a slave trader should mosques be
torn down
are you listening to this yeah
yeah i just wanted to make sure that my
girlfriend is listening to this
garbage that's coming out of your mouth
what i love the fact is that you
disagree with this
here's a guy that was born in iran who
loves the country your great grandfather
built
this is a guy that escaped iran to come
to america and i'm defending your
country
i'm an immigrant proudly i
represent america so am i so why do you
love america
i'm an i'm an immigrant as well
in fact i'm a naturalized citizen are
you a naturalized citizen i
am yeah so am i were you
were you born here no i wasn't
i was born in japan in a military and
because i was born in japan
after the war before there was an
immigration and naturalization treaty
with the country of japan that didn't
exist in 1947
i i was naturalized probably the same
way you are
i am different i have an immigration
difference naturalization
certificate the same way you do were you
born in a military base
yes but but it's slightly different you
cannot explain me being born in iran
and you being i i just explained to you
why
i was naturalized yeah you know it it's
uh
look i i understand that there's better
places to go to that's going to be safer
interviews to be done but i was
wondering to know if you were going to
ask some questions
answer some questions just out of
curiosity you're somebody that's written
a lot
who would you say the best president
we've had in the last hundred years
the best president we had in the last 30
years
i'd say barack obama barack obama who
else would you say
huh who else outside of brock
you know i don't have to tell you these
things you know this is good
you know something these are ridiculous
questions this is
sitting here you have to be the greatest
what is my favorite movie
what is my favorite novel or whatever i
don't answer questions like this
i don't tell you what my favorite novel
is or my favorite movie
i don't have to tell you what my
favorite did we get
saying we can't ask questions on movies
or things like this
so we were just told let's do an
interview with questions right is that
kind of what it was
so you said barack obama is your
favorite president fair enough let's
just go with
that barack obama is your favorite
president here's what barack obama said
february 10 2014 as one of our founding
fathers
the person who drafted our declaration
of independence
somebody who not only was an
extraordinary political leader but also
one of our great scientific and
cultural leaders thomas jefferson
represents
what's best in america do you agree with
barack obama
no i don't i don't think owning slavery
represents what's best in america
running slaves
i think to go back and to assume a time
where every one of our parents or
lineage is linked to either being a
slave owner or a slave
this includes me i'm a syrian and
armenian
so i'm sure you're familiar with the
assyrian and the armenian genocide
yes okay so i can go back and say it's
not fair to do this
and sure i can ask for a lot of things
but that's history
so if america wants to put a statue up i
don't see an issue with that i don't
know why you see an issue with that
well and you haven't been listening to
me because i've explained it
i have been but you haven't answered a
lot of questions and and maybe it's
safer to go to a place where you give
them the questions to ask you where the
interview cannot ask you any question
you should have told me up front these
are 98 questions you can't ask
we wouldn't have done this interview but
if you agree to the interview
you don't want to do the interview
that's good let's just
nitty little questions like who's asking
me
who's my favorite yes yes because your
favorite president said
because your favorite president said
thomas jefferson
represents what's best in america that's
why
that's what you're doing you know what
you're doing you know what you're doing
what am i doing you don't like the fact
that i wrote that article for the new
yorker no no i
i actually love what you want to do with
your videos
what you want to do is pick a fight with
absolutely not i watch every
single one of your videos and let me
tell you what was beautiful about the
videos that you have
every single one of the interviews you
done i watched it was emotional to see
you
and to see you and i believe the
gentleman's name is shannon
lanier it was beautiful seeing the two
of you guys together
it was beautiful seeing you bringing a
family together it was beautiful seeing
you taking there to history together
it was a wonderful thing to do because
that's how you unify that's what we need
in america
that's something where it gets me
emotional to sit there and watch and say
i love this we need more of this
so before you jump to conclusion and
judge this guy interviewing you
you have to understand that this guy was
inspired by what you did and he's asking
you basic questions to see where you are
with why the statue is you can't answer
questions
i can answer questions i answered your
why do you thinking why i think we're
going to take down the statue of
thomas jefferson yeah then i asked you
some other basic questions you refused
to answer but basic questions like who's
my favorite president yes
people ask those guys that's a that's a
baloney question
it's that it's for you to say you can
say that yes i can say that
and you ask me what you ask me what what
what what country i believe is the best
and i answered it to you
i think that's a baloney question
you asked me what was what i what did
you ask me what is my favorite
what country do you believe is the
greatest who i think is the greatest
country in
the world you know
you can't answer that can you yeah i did
say it what is it
ask ask the guy you're in the studio
with i asked what
yeah i'm interviewing you not them
what what i'm asking you i'm not
interviewing these guys
no i know you're not you well if you
can't remember what my answer was
maybe one of the guys in your studio can
remember the answer
and the follow-up question was why do
you think america is the greatest
country how can't you answer that
question
i did what was it i said because i said
it is so that's your answer
that's my answer what an incredible
answer because you said
so if you got millions of 20 year olds
that are watching you in america
who are on your side hoping to learn
from you they're hoping somebody with
your level of wisdom can teach them
why is america such a great country
because i said it is that's all it is
okay
all right uh i mean based on that uh uh
i will do one last question for you and
i have a feeling i know where this
answer is going
how do you feel about the economist
right back here in the painting if you
look closely in this painting
there are two books behind me in this
painting
we have john f kennedy here we have
einstein lincoln
we have the shah here we have milton
friedman and mlk
they're in a bank vault debating two
books the two books sitting there had
this painting custom-made
one you recognize on the top possibly if
you can see it one is communist
manifesto
the other one is atlas shrugged by ein
rand you recognize both names yes
yeah what would you say about karl marx
what do you think about him
i i don't think anything about him how
about ayn rand
i don't think anything about her either
very cool what do you think about donald
trump i don't think anything about him
either
this is a very interesting interview but
i can tell you one thing for a fact it's
very uh
i learn a lot it's good i learned a lot
today i learned a lot
i learned i learned that uh uh you
prefer
easy questions than tough ones and tough
ones kind of irritate you a little bit
which i can't
tough ones like who's your favorite
president
your favorite president's love admires
jefferson that's because your favorite
question who's the first
african-american president
said that thomas jefferson represents
what's
best in america yeah i know he did and
you know what
i disagree with him because i don't
think owning
slaves represents what's best in america
nobody do you think that slavery was one
of the best
was what's best about this kind of one
of the worst things that was done in
america
okay and maybe you disagree and maybe
you disagree with uh barack obama too
the only thing i disagree is why take
the statue and replace it with harriet
tubman rather than put it in a different
place
i don't disagree with you on a lot of
things okay
i'm disagreeing with why take it and
replace it why not just put it elsewhere
and recognize i told you i answered that
question
and there you go so i answered your
question as well
i answered your question as well yeah
okay good
yeah i got to tell you i've had a blast
with you
yeah are one of my favorite interviews
of all time
yeah i wish you nothing but the best
okay all good take care of yourself
goodbye bye bye what a [ __ ] [ __ ]
uh you know what this is this is all the
notes i prepared for the interview every
single interview he had done every
new one old one year old six years old
seven years
i watched every single one of them out
of respect to
him and his lineage and i was curious to
know why
he wanted to move why not just put
another statue there with harriet tubman
right next to it why having to take away
the statue and put it at a different
place
what are your thoughts did you sit there
and say pat i think i absolutely
disagree with you
tell me why i want to hear your thoughts
or you may say i agree with
you why do you agree with me and also do
you think he really loves america
when i said why do you love america why
couldn't he give an answer this was a
90-minute interview
and it wasn't going anywhere and he
wasn't answering any questions was there
any unfair questions that were asked in
this interview regarding
him being part of the lineage of
jefferson to want to move it
remove it to another place what are your
thoughts i really really want to hear
your thoughts comment below and by the
way
if you watch this interview and you kind
of want to know a little bit more about
some of the ways i think i got two other
videos i want you to watch
one is my response to what happened with
george freud's death and black lives
matter if you've never watched a click
over here to watch that
or if you want to see economically how i
believe or see things with
capitalism and socialism click over here
to watch the debate he and i uh
professor richard wolf and i had a very
very
well-known marxist socialist professor
we got very heated
but we got off the conversation having a
great time together so if you've not
watched us click over here
if you've not watched my response click
over here and if you're not subscribed
to the channel please do so
thanks for watching everybody take care
bye
you